did anybody know about your secret
wedding i told no one about this wedding
no one and i also asked corey to not
tell anyone as well evelyn explains why
she lied to us and most importantly her
family about being married to corey plus
he was horrible babes i know i can't
imagine after thinking he didn't survive
the category 5 hurricane ellie finally
reunites with victor when i saw her
i had some hopes to be happy again and i
must say
although i doubted this love at first it
might be the real deal
thank you
might be
hey 90 day fans fam it's melicia
i can't bring you a full recap this week
because we at et are deep in emmy's
coverage but i still wanted to talk to
you about two must-see moments oh oh my
god by the way for those of you who are
wondering if the recaps are my own
thoughts or if i write and produce them
the answer is yes to all three these are
my own thoughts i write and produce the
recaps but of course i have a wonderful
team behind me including a fantastic
editor
fantastic he impresses me every week
okay enough about what's going on over
here let's talk corey and evelyn i don't
feel good about lying to my family but
it's more like i try to put it in my
head like i'm hiding instead of lying so
she's basically been lying to herself as
well trying this dress makes the scene
all
extra real i'm like oh my god oh my god
oh my god this is happening what am i
going to do after acting as if she's
stressed out about a decision she
already made evelyn reveals she legally
married corey a year ago because his
visa was expiring with no other way for
him to stay here in the country with me
i agreed to marry him and she said she
lied about it because divorce is
unacceptable in her family no matter
what happens in the marriages if it's
unhappy or not they believe on not
getting divorced so she figured if she
married him in secret she could get a
divorce in secret if she ever needed to
senora
this also means that cory was dating the
woman named jenny who he met in peru
while he was married to evelyn see her
sister's face says it all
how does learning that they've been
lying this entire time make you feel as
a viewer
do you feel bamboozled i got all these
mixed emotions did you see this coming
and i just got really emotional and
started crying or could you care less it
was mostly a last-minute decision
me i'm more toward the latter end but
it's still a while to know that evelyn
was able to keep up an act like this
i'm sure it got tiring i also wonder
what is it going to take for her sisters
to trust her again
yeah she's been lying to their faces
you know it's the worst when someone
close to you just reveals themselves and
you're like who are you
who are you really
[Music]
crying
oh my god
all right moving on we're not going to
spend too much time here but i wanted
you to see ellie finally reunite with
victor after he survived a category 5
hurricane
just so you could get a gist of how they
interact with each other he made it
it feels so good to be with victor
welcome home baby
[Laughter]
but i know we're gonna have to face the
truth that
our future is completely unknown right
now
when you see the island it's gonna break
your heart
my heart is break but it's back again
because you're here oh
that's so sweet
[Music]
so far it seems genuine
you can always tell by the kiss
but i did speak to ellie recently and i
asked her if she's thought about what
she would do if he turns out to be
someone other than she thinks i mean i
would just have to move on you know and
kind of uh
i've done it you know we've all done it
before so
yeah um but you know i i will cross that
bridge if it comes all right well next
week corey decides that he wants to
admit what really went down with this
woman jenny from peru you remember that
girl i told you about jenny
it was a little more serious than i went
on if you don't tell evelyn the full
truth about jenny i'm gonna have to tell
her
i'm so afraid that she will never give
me another chance should love really be
that complicated
[Music]
all right 90 day fans fam i have to go
but make sure you stick with e.t because
we are covering it all i will see you
next time
[Music]
you